الخوف من اتساع رقعه المواجهه للتحول الى
تصعيد اشمل اصبح هاجسا اقليميا ودوليا
وعلى امتداد ايام الحرب المئه تلاحقت
التصريحات بين التحذير ومحاوله خفض
التصعيد وصولا الى توقع هذا
التوسع السفينه الحربيه يو اس اس ايزنهاور
في الطريق لردع وتاجيل المزيد من العدوان
ضد اسرائيل ومنع هذا الصراع من
الانتشار
[موسيقى]
هناك عدد من الخطوات التي يتخذها الحوثيون
ووكلاء اخرون لايران في العراق وسوريا
تهدد الاستقرار وتهدد باحتمال نشوب صراع
عازمون على انلا نرى
تصعيدا لا نريد ان نرى الحرب بين اسرائيل
وحماس تتسع في المنطقه ولكننا لن نتراجع
ايضا عن مهمه الدفاع عن انفسنا او مصالحنا
او
شركائنا
نعمل على ضمان عدم تصاعد هذا الصراع خارج
نطاق
غزه لا احد يريد ان يرى تصعيدا للصراع في
الشرق الاوسط لكن من غير المقبول ان تهدد
حريه
الملاحه نحن متاهب للتعامل مع احتمال توسع
القتال ال ساحات اخر قه
وبعده اشغر شخته ايران لا تسعى الى اتساع
دائره الحرب في المنطقه لكن مواصله قتل
النساء والاطفال سيؤدي الى نفاد صبر قوات
المقاومه وشعوب المنطقه حرصنا منذ اليوم
الاول من اندلاع المواجهات الى السعي لخف
التصعيد والتهدئه وصولا الى وقف القتال
بشكل تام وذلك لحقن الدماء وتجنيب المنطقه
خطر الانزلاق في دائره عنف اوسع تدفع
ثمنها شعوبنا التي انهكتها الحروب
والصراعات نحن في لبنان لا يزال ضبط النفس
هو هي الاشاره الطبيعيه ولكن هذه
الاستفزازات والاعتداءات على المدنيين
وعلى الصحفيين وعلى الاراضي اللبنانيه لا
يمكن ان تستمر الى ابد
الابدين لا ازال اشعر بقلق بالغ اذاء خطر
انتشار هذا الصراع على المستوى
الاقليمي